according to Stephen crashen the
foremost linguist in the field of second
language acquisition we acquire language
when we receive and understand input
that is a little beyond our current
level this certainly makes sense but
does it tell the whole story is
comprehensible input all we need to
learn languages successfully or are we
still missing other pieces of the puzzle
I'll share my answer with you right here
in this video hi I'm lucran perello I'm
a Language Coach who speaks 14 languages
and on this channel I help people learn
foreign languages more efficiently
faster and in a fun way if you've never
heard of Stephen Crasher before then
he's someone who's worked you should
really get to know crashing is a widely
published linguist whose ideas form the
backbone of second language acquisition
that is language learning as we know it
today in particular crashing is known
for his many conjectures hypothesis and
other ideas two of the most popular
being the concept of comprehensible
input as well as the input hypothesis
that goes along with it
comprehensible input is input that is
slightly above your current language
skill in crashes writings you also see
this referred to as I plus 1 where I is
your level right now and the plus one
refers to whatever the next level above
yours might be with that in mind let's
now dig into the input hypothesis in
crashing's own words the input
hypothesis suggests that we acquire
language in only one way when we
understand messages when we obtain
comprehensible input we acquire language
in other words when we understand what
we hear or what we read when we
understand the message
according to crashing if the input
hypothesis is true then a few other
things must also be true first language
acquisition is effortless it involves no
energy and no work all an acquire has to
do is to understand messages and second
language acquisition is involuntary
given comprehensible input and a lack of
emotional barriers language acquisition
will take place the acquirer has no
choice
if you've never heard those ideas before
then they might seem pretty shocking
it's rare to hear anyone use words like
effortless and involuntary when it comes
to language learning in fact I think
we're more used to hearing words like
difficult and frustrating whenever the
subject comes up so what gives where is
the disconnect between crashes Theory
and the apparent reality that so many of
us language Learners face every day to
better understand where crashing is
coming from I think it's useful to
define a couple of terms first let's
talk about explicit learning and second
let's examine implicit learning explicit
learning is the kind of learning that
takes active effort if you studied a
language in school this is likely the
type of learning that you engaged in
most of the time it involves
deliberately trying to take what you do
not know and drill it into your memory
implicit learning is quite the opposite
this type of learning is done passively
usually through mere exposure to the
information you're trying to learn a
good example of this is how you learned
your mother tongue when you were a child
you probably never had to do grammar
drills to learn the vertices of your
first language it's just happened
naturally
when crashing says that comprehensible
input makes language acquisition
effortless he's saying that it provides
an optimal environment for implicit
learning again learning that is done
passively or rather than actively by
contrast the effortful language learning
that you're used to most likely involves
little comprehensible input and a lot of
explicit learning which is by definition
more difficult while the idea of
effortless language learning certainly
sounds more appealing than the
frustrating learning experiences most of
us had in school I am not entirely
convinced that an all-comprehensible
input-based implicit learning method is
the way to go
oppression may have missed the Mark here
for one reason a flaw in implicit
learning that I've encountered often
when trying to put it into practice
myself the flaw implicit learning though
effective is incredibly slow often
painfully so think back to the example I
gave for implicit learning A Child
Learning his or her first language
unlike adults children have no use for
explicit grammar instruction they're
able to learn their native language
perfectly solely through absorbing crash
in so-called comprehensible input the
problem however is that this method
takes incredible amounts of such input
and takes years to show meaningful
results it's easy to forget for example
that most children do not reach a
conversational level in their mother
tongues until they're between three and
five years old
I don't know about you but I don't have
a way to get comprehensible input 24
hours a day seven days a week in any of
my target languages and certainly not
for years even if I could spend my time
that way I doubt I would want to I have
a life another interest after all
comprehensible input is clearly useful
but wouldn't it be better if there were
a way to you know speed things up a
little bit that's where Crasher and I
diverge I believe that there is a better
way for adults to learn foreign
languages one that can enable most of us
to reach a conversational level quickly
without being as effortful and
frustrating as explicit language
learning often can be while crashing
believes that knowledge gained through
explicit learning that is explicit
knowledge can never turn into implicit
knowledge I believe that explicit
knowledge can often facilitate and
reinforce information gained implicitly
let me give you a practical example
Impressions model technically called the
no interface model since it holds That
explicit knowledge does not interface
with implicit knowledge learning occurs
only through comprehensible input you
expose yourself to text or audio in your
target language that is calibrated to be
just above your level and then learning
just takes as long as it takes you do
not worry about things like native
language translations or grammar
explanations because they can't do
anything for you they're not
comprehensible input so they're
effectively useless
in my preferred model technically
referred to as the weak interface model
since it holds That explicit knowledge
can interface weekly with implicit
knowledge you would expose yourself to
comprehensible text or audio in your
target language in much the same way but
you would supplement that exposure with
external learning AIDS many of which
would be in your own native language
these can include translations of the
text you're reading or even short
grammar explanations that help you make
sense of grammar patterns in the audio
you are listening to learning with this
weak interface model is much faster than
crash's alternative merely because it
allows you to exert some control over
the speed at which you absorb new
information you don't have to wait for
your brain to magically decipher the
meaning of a word or grammar pattern
through context but rather you're able
to turn to a translation or grammar
notes and discover instantly what those
new things mean these learning AIDS do
not try to do all the work for you
because they can't but they can give
your learning A helpful nudge when your
brain is not being the new information
as fast as you would like to be clear
I'm not exactly saying that crashing in
his input hypothesis isn't wrong
comprehensible input should be the
foundation of any language learning plan
all I'm saying is that it's not
sufficient in and of itself to provide
an efficient and enjoyable learning
experience especially for adult Learners
like you and me
I myself try to get as much
comprehensible input as I can but I
always supplement that input with
learning tools and AIDS in my native
language or a language in a well so that
I can make the learning process as
efficient as possible let me give you a
few examples of what I'm talking about
before I read and listen to a target
language dialogue for example I always
make sure I obtain or create a bilingual
copy of the text in both my native and
Target languages this gives me a way to
quickly fill in the gaps of
understanding as I mentally process the
target language content as I get my
input if I find that there's a grammar
structure that I repeatedly fail to
understand I won't just gloss over it
until my brain figures it out instead
I'll go online and read a short
explanation on the grammar point in my
native language and maybe even take a
short quiz on it if one is available as
my input levels increase I do not simply
let my pronunciation skills grow
naturally based upon the pronunciation
of the native speakers I listen to
rather I seek out feedback from others
and even do a little technical research
on the sound system of my target
language using these explicit learning
tools and following the weak interface
model helps me to quickly gain a solid
foundation in my target languages at a
rate that is much faster than I could
accomplish using comprehensible input
alone after that Foundation is built and
I've reached a fluent level in the
language I can then transition to a
learning style more dependent on
implicit learning as crashing suggests
and this is what I suggest for you as
well get lots of comprehensible input
but don't try to make implicit learning
all you do there is still a real
functional use for materials that
encourage explicit learning like
translations subtitles and grammar
explanations because of this you should
not abandon them instead combine both
implicit and explicit learning content
so that you can learn your target
language both quickly and effectively
all right that's all I have for you
today but before we go let's review what
we've learned Stephen crashen one of the
foremost linguists in the field of
second language acquisition believes
that language can only be learned
through use of comprehensible input or
input that is just above your current
skill level well I personally do
acknowledge that comprehensible input is
the best kind of input for language
learning I do not believe that it's all
we need there are still a few puzzle
pieces we need in order to learn
languages fast and to a high level
differently for crashing I believe that
certain explicit learning tools like
translations grammar explanations and
even feedback given in your native
language can help you learn a new
language while saving lots of time that
you would otherwise spend waiting for
your brain to implicitly absorb the
language as such I believe it is best to
learn new languages in a way that
combines both crashing's implicit
learning methods and some of the more
typical methods for explicit learning
that we are already familiar with this
is because explicit learning facilitates
the acquisition of implicit knowledge
which is essential to learning a
language well on a final note if you
like like to learn more about crashing's
input hypothesis and even the competing
weak interface model among others take a
look down in the description box I've
left a few links that will help you to
dive deeper into these fascinating
topics oh and if you've got an opinion
on whether you learn best implicitly
explicitly or somewhere in between feel
free to share it with me in the comments
section below
all right I'll see you in the next video
thanks for watching and as always happy
language learning